alors oui le virus circule dans les
établissements scolaires mais pas plus
qu'ailleurs et l'éducation de nos
enfants elle n'est pas négociable
l'école n'est pas négociable
c'est pourquoi nous devons prendre nos
responsabilités oui il faut freiner le
virus aussi nous allons fermer durant
trois semaines les crèches les écoles
les collèges et des lycées
mais oui nous devons préserver
l'éducation et l'apprentissage
c'est pour cela que le calendrier
scolaire sera adapté pour ne pas laisser
nos enfants
seul et sans apprendre de manière très
concrète cela signifie que la semaine
prochaine
les cours pour les écoles collèges et
lycées se feront à la maison sauf comme
au printemps 2020 pour les enfants des
soignants et de quelques autres
professions qui seront accueillis de
même que les enfants en situation de
handicap qui doivent continuer à pouvoir
être accueillis dans le secteur médico
social
les deux semaines suivantes soit à
partir du 12 avril
la france entière quelle que soit la
zone de vacances sera placée en vacances
de printemps
la rentrée aura donc lieu pour tous le
26 avril physiquement pour les
maternelles et les primaires à distance
pour les collèges les lycées le 3 mai
les collégiens et les lycéens pourront
retrouver physiquement leur
établissement le cas échéant avec des
jauges adapté